we reported earlier that Starbucks will
close its stores and corporate offices
on May 29th for a company-wide racial
bias training the announcement comes in
response to public protests and calls to
boycott Starbucks protesters are upset
about the arrest of two black men at a
Philadelphia store last week Gail is at
another Starbucks in Philadelphia
Gail good morning again thank you very
much John joining me now to discuss the
incident and how the company is handling
it is Starbucks executive chairman
that's Howard Schultz it is an interview
that you will see only on CBS this
morning and Howard we really appreciate
you taking the time to join us this
morning thank you listen we have all
heard the phrase driving while black
shopping while black and now Howard
there's a hashtag that says Starbucks
while black you see and you hear that
and you think what well I'm embarrassed
ashamed I think what occurred was
reprehensible at every single level I
think I take it very personally as
everyone in our company does and we're
committed to making it right the
announcement we made yesterday about
closing our stores 8,000 stores closed
to do significant training with our
people it's just the beginning of what
we will do to transform the way we do
business and educate our people on
unconscious cost you millions of dollars
to it'll cost it will cost millions of
dollars but I have always viewed this
and things like this as not an expense
but an investment in our people in our
company and we're better than this and I
think people expect us to be at a higher
level than many other companies and I
understand that
you know I've heard the phrase racial
bias training what exactly does that
mean people are saying to me Gail this
is just a big PR stunt this is an
overreaction
what does Howard and his company really
expect to accomplish in a training
session in an afternoon we've had two
company-wide meetings I held one in
Seattle three days ago since this
happened yes I held one yesterday here
in Philadelphia and I think the truth of
the matter is that every one of us has a
different life experience and that
different life experience
unfortunately produces a level of bias
or unconscious bias about what we feel
as people and I think we have an
opportunity with the help of sherrilyn
Ifill from the n-double a-c-p and Bryan
Stevenson and Heather McGee people who
have been in this space for a long time
to help guide us supply it's even said
of the equal justice in Asia and I want
to I want to say something that I think
is very important this is not going to
be a one-day event where we're gonna do
something and leave we're gonna sick
stay with this it's going to be
significant it's going to endure and
we're gonna transform the way we do
business I also think it's an
opportunity for healing
yesterday I I spent time with the white
manager who did make the 9-1-1 call
and it still with the company no she has
left the company I think there's a
unique opportunity for her and the two
gentlemen to sit down and potentially
have some kind of reconciliation do you
see that happening I do I think it's
gonna be possible I think she's
interested in doing it and I think kevin
has spent time with the two young men
and I think we Kevin Johnson the
Starbucks CEO yes
so perhaps something good can come out
of this and by that I mean this has
highlighted for us that we have more
work to do as a company and and I think
you know race is a very difficult
subject to discuss we learned that three
years ago you tried with the race
together race together campaign and it
did not go well no we did it didn't and
I think one of the reasons is that many
people in America are not prepared to
talk about risk I understand that but
this is a systemic problem in the
country that's not to say what happened
at Starbucks is not an issue it is an
issue and it's an issue that we will
address we will fix we take it
personally and I can promise you that I
am deeply deeply committed to
comprehensive training for our people I
would like to know more about the
conversation with the manager yesterday
what did you say what did she say how is
she feeling why did she make that call
well yeah I think for her she is
suffering herself and in her own way I
think she recognizes that perhaps that
call should not have been made
I don't think she intended when she made
the call for the police to arrive and
arrest the two young men
what did she then was gonna happen I
think she probably thought that the
police were going to talk to the men
about what they were doing and why they
were there and I think you have to say
and looking at the tape that she
demonstrated her own level of
unconscious bias and in looking at the
table ask yourself whether or not that
in fact was racial profiling yeah if is
there any doubt in your mind that the
call would not have been made had there
been two white men and you know white
customers in the store was saying look
I've been sitting here no one has said
anything to me the two black men by the
way in their 20s were there to meet a
realtor that discuss a business deal you
know there's no doubt in my mind that
the reason that they were called was
because they were african-american and I
think I'm I'm embarrassed by that I'm
ashamed of that that's not who Starbucks
is that's not who we have been and
that's not who we're going to be does
she no think she made the wrong decision
the manager I think she regrets to call
e-911 yes what if anything does a
company plan to do for the two black men
I know Kevin Johnson the CEO is met with
them have you all had any discussions
about what if anything Starbucks should
do could do for the young men I think
think about how they handle the two at
Howard I think it's actually they not
many people have recognized the fact
that this could have turned into
something much much worse that they
acted in a very passive way and thank
God for that
they were very calm and cooperative yes
yes so what we have tried to do with the
two young men and Kevin has met with
them has asked them what can Starbucks
given our resources and the capabilities
we have they have an interest in real
estate what can we do to help advise
them and support their own business and
endeavours and I think what will come
out of this is that given the resources
that we do have that we will provide
them with the foundation of learning and
provide them with an opportunity to be
part of our company either directly or
indirectly as a result of this situation
right now I have more questions yet
we're on live TV we're out of time can
you stick around and I can continue the
conversation will run the interview at 8
o'clock course I know you have another
meeting at 8 o'clock yeah for now right
now we'll send it back to you all in the
studio Thank You Gail a really good
interview and a lot of new information
there that we learned this morning about
steps that Starbucks is going to take
and about a possible meeting between
that manager and those two men thank you
so much Gail we'll look for to the rest
of that conversation